.
(Alain) Nein, nein, nein.
Okay?
Er schafft es nicht.
(Anita) Darf ich etwas sagen?
- Ja.
Wir ziehen hinten und vorn
die Bremse an
und lassen ihn hier stehen,
damit er nicht überhitzt.
Ja.
Wir haben ein riesiges Problem.
Wir stehen mit dem Wohnwagen
und Johns Auto
mitten auf dem Kiesweg und kommen
weder vorwärts noch rückwärts.
Ein Leben im sonnigen Griechenland -
davon träumen Alain Aegerter
und Anita Thomi.
Mit im Gepäck:
24 Giftschlangen und 41 Schildkröten.
Ihnen wird es dort auch gefallen.
Das Haus im Emmental
ist längst verkauft,
die neuen Besitzer
ziehen bereits ein,
doch die Einfuhrpapiere
für die Tiere fehlen.
Wir müssten eigentlich
seit dem 30. Mai draussen sein.
Im Camper vor ihrem ehemaligen
Wohnhaus finden sie Unterschlupf.
Mahlzeit.
- Guten Appetit.
So schnell wie möglich
nach Schweden möchte Familie Rotzler.
Wir lebten den Schweizer Traum:
ein anständiger Job,
eine Familie und ein Häuschen.
Aber irgendwie verspürten wir
immer eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit.
Im hohen Norden
machen sie sich auf Haussuche.
Kein einfaches Unterfangen
mit drei kleinen Kindern.
Wir sind
in einem fremden Haus, Kinder.
Nach langer Suche
finden sie das passende Objekt:
eine Ferienanlage mitten im Wald.
Wir kamen an
und fühlten uns gleich wohl.
Das Mansion am Meer in Kanada
haben sie schon gekauft,
die Wohnung in der Schweiz aufgelöst.
Barbara Hasenböhler
und ihr Partner Thomas Range
stehen kurz vor der Abreise.
In fünf Wochen sehen wir ihn wieder.
Aber dann bricht die Pandemie aus
und die beiden
sitzen in der Schweiz fest.
Als sie endlich nach Kanada ausreisen
können, ist die Freude gross.
(Barbara) So schön.
Ihr gemeinsames Abenteuer
kann endlich beginnen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Spät abends am südlichen Peloponnes
in Griechenland:
Fast unbemerkt kommen zwei Fahrzeuge
mit Schweizer Kennzeichen in Koroni,
einem Fischerdorf, an.
Auswanderer Alain Aegerter ist vor
zwei Tagen im Emmental aufgebrochen,
zusammen mit
seiner Lebensgefährtin Anita Thomi.
Stopp!
Hä? Was?
Geh auf die andere Seite.
- Okay.
Geradeaus rückwärts. Stopp.
Die lange Reise
steckt ihnen in den Knochen.
Doch noch sind sie nicht am Ziel.
Wir lassen ihn hier so stehen.
- Ja, klar.
Gut.
- Es spricht nichts dagegen.
Der Wohnwagen
bleibt vorerst an der Hauptstrasse.
Die Bremse?
- Ja, sie ist angezogen.- Gut.
Es ist eine ziemlich steile,
wilde Strasse bis zum Haus.
Nun schauen wir mal,
wie weit wir kommen.
Alain fährt mit dem Wohnmobil voraus.
Anita kommt hinterher -
mit im Auto ihre Schwiegereltern.
Die beiden wollen
ein paar Tage Ferien machen.
Eigentlich wollten Alain und Anita
schon vor Wochen starten.
Doch ohne die nötigen Papiere
für die Reptilien
keine Einreise in Griechenland.
Nun haben sie die Geduld verloren
und sind ohne ihre Tiere los.
Ich hatte die Nase voll
von dieser Warterei.
In der Schweiz regnete es ja nur
und unser Haus ist verkauft.
Sie sagten zwar immer,
wir seien willkommen,
aber wir und der Hund lebten
mehr oder weniger im Wohnwagen.
Es konnte sich jeweils
nur eine Person hinsetzen.
Das ist scheisse.
Jetzt kümmern sich Freunde
im Emmental um die Reptilien,
bis das Problem mit der Einfuhr
gelöst ist.
Shit.
* Er zieht die Handbremse an. *
Es wären nur noch ein paar Hundert
Meter bis zu ihrem Grundstück.
Schade.
Das Wohnmobil
ist hinten offenbar zu schwer.
Wollen wir uns nicht zuerst beraten?
Das Auto muss rauf, Anita.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich klar.
Meinst du, wir kriegen es rauf?
Oder ist es aussichtslos?
Nein, es ist nicht aussichtslos.
- Okay.
Wenn es nicht aussichtslos ist,
habe ich noch etwas Geduld.
Jö.
* Sie lacht. *
Die Kisten lassen sie am Wegesrand.
Alain will sie später holen.
Oh, Achtung,
da fliegen Steine, gefährlich.
Er kommt hier nicht mehr weg.
Er muss wieder ganz nach unten.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Juhu!
Geradeso geschafft.
Huhu.
Home, sweet home.
Das haben wir uns
nun sauer verdient.
Wir sind hier.
Endlich angekommen.
Also, komm.
* Anita lacht. *
So, jetzt bist du drinnen.
* Lachen *
(Erleichtert) So.
(Lachend) Du bist ein Idiot.
Hier ist auch gleich ein Bett.
Hier ist ein Dampfabzug.
In Witterswil bei Familie Rotzler
geht es in grossen Schritten
Richtung Schweden.
Ihr Einfamilienhaus
konnten sie bereits verkaufen.
In den letzten fünf Jahren hat es
Jonas nach und nach selbst renoviert.
Es ist ein total tolles Haus
und wir investierten sehr viel.
Wir gestalteten sehr viel
nach unseren Wünschen.
Daher tut es ein bisschen weh,
es in andere Hände geben zu müssen,
aber wir tun es ja,
um uns unseren Wunsch zu erfüllen.
Daher ist es gut so, wie es ist.
Ihre Möbel hat Familie Rotzler
grösstenteils weggegeben,
die meisten Zügelkisten schon
gepackt, und heute ist Abschiedsfest.
Jana, möchtest du
die Toast-Chefin sein?
Hast du die Masse schon vorbereitet?
- Nein.
Sabrinas Eltern
helfen bei den Vorbereitungen.
Es ist ziemlich chaotisch
und ich bin froh,
dass wir bald weg sind.
Danke. Wir müssen so viel machen,
bis das Brett voll ist.
Sabrinas Mutter Heidi lässt Tochter
und Enkelkinder nur ungern ziehen.
Es ist ihr Traum
und sie sollen ihn leben.
Ich hoffe, dass dieser Traum ...
... wirklich gut wird.
Auf die junge Familie
wartet in Schweden eine Ferienanlage
mit rund 30 Gästezimmern
und insgesamt 60 Betten.
Mir verschlug es die Sprache,
als ich sah,
wie viel Arbeit das sein wird.
Boah, das ist heftig.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle,
dass sie 60 Gäste haben werden ...
Für 60 Personen zu kochen,
ist nicht gerade ein Pappenstiel.
Ja, es ist viel Arbeit.
Ja.
Ich weiss, dass es viel Arbeit ist,
aber es ist auch wunderschön.
Wir lassen es im ersten halben Jahr
ziemlich langsam angehen
und nehmen wenige Buchungen an,
damit es nicht so viel wird.
Gestern erhielten wir
die erste Buchung.
Für wann?
- Für Anfang Juli.
Ui!
- Es sind nur vier Personen.
Genau.
* Muntere Musik *
Ich dachte, draussen sei noch einer.
Einen Sonnenschirm habe ich,
aber ich brauche eine starke Person.
Wie wollt ihr ihn hinstellen?
Zum Abschied hat Familie Rotzler
noch einmal alle eingeladen:
Freunde, Bekannte und Verwandte.
Hallo, Götti.
- Hallo.
So einfach zusammenkommen
wird bald nicht mehr möglich sein.
* Lachen *
Kommst du auch zu uns, Fiona?
Hören uns alle?
- (Mehrere) Ja.
Hört ihr uns auch?
Dürfen wir kurz etwas sagen?
Es ist sehr schön,
dass ihr alle gekommen seid.
Ihr alle wart uns
in unserem Leben sehr nah.
Vielen herzlichen Dank für das,
was ihr mitgebracht habt.
Vielen herzlichen Dank
an unsere Eltern,
die uns immer sehr tatkräftig
beim Thema Haus
und bei unserem jetzigen Vorhaben
unterstützt haben.
Ohne unsere Eltern
wäre das nicht möglich gewesen,
vielen herzlichen Dank.
Wir freuen uns, euch alle
in Schweden zu begrüssen.- Klar.
Vorfreude und
auch ein wenig Abschiedsschmerz.
Sie sahen sich
mindestens einmal pro Woche.
Das wird uns schon fehlen.
Schon in zwei Wochen
verlässt Familie Rotzler die Schweiz.
Puffy.
Nur kurz, die Zähne zusammenbeissen.
Bleib.
* Sanfte Musik *
Auf Prince Edward Island
ist der Herbst angebrochen.
Drei Monate ist es bereits her,
dass Barbara Hasenböhler
und ihr Partner Thomas Range
ihr altes Leben in der Schweiz
hinter sich gelassen haben.
Meine Küche
ist der schönste Arbeitsplatz,
den man sich vorstellen kann.
Hier sehe ich das Meer und wenn
ich abwasche, sehe ich den Garten.
Es ist echt ein Traum.
* Sanfte Musik *
Die eingelegten Tomaten
sind für Gäste,
die Barbara dereinst bekochen möchte.
Das Mansion am Meer wollen sie
in eine luxuriöse Herberge
mit sieben Zimmern verwandeln.
Schon vor Wochen
hätte der Umbau beginnen sollen.
Es gab wohl auch in der Kommuni-
kation ein paar Missverständnisse.
Dabei geht es um Bau-Codes.
Da es sich in unserem Fall
um ein "Hotel" handeln wird,
sind die Auflagen
für öffentlich zugängliche Gebäude
schon etwas strenger,
als wenn wir für uns privat
einen Anbau planen würden.
In der Garage sollen drei grosse
Zimmer mit eigenem Bad entstehen,
vier weitere
im 570 m2 grossen Wohnhaus.
Die fehlende Baubewilligung aber
ist nicht ihr einziges Problem.
Barbara und Thomas
brauchen auch Leute,
die ihre Ideen umsetzen -
Handwerker wie Curtis.
Er ist auf Sandstrahlen
spezialisiert.
Thomas, hi.
Cool German Shepards.
Nicht nur innen wollen sie umbauen,
auch aussen müssen sie renovieren.
Durch die strenge Witterung
und die Nähe zum Meer
blättert am ganzen Haus die Farbe ab.
Anstatt alle paar Jahre
neu zu streichen,
möchte Barbara die Farbe
an der Fassade entfernen lassen.
Das sei schöner und günstiger.
(Barbara)
Das Besondere: Curtis ist
der einzige Fachmann auf der Insel,
der sich auf ihre Anfrage
gemeldet hat.
(Curtis)
(Barbara)
Er spricht sehr langsam,
aber wahrscheinlich versteht er
trotzdem etwas von seiner Arbeit.
Man hat hier allerdings
auch keine riesige Auswahl.
Dies ist eine Insel.
Das bedeutet auch, dass es
nicht unzählige Handwerker gibt.
Wenn man mal einen hat,
muss man ihn fast festbinden.
Hier herrscht
ein unglaublicher Handwerkermangel.
And? Did you do the tour?
I walked around it
a couple of times.
I'm trying to break it up
into sections.- Okay.
Curtis scheint zumindest
interessiert zu sein.
Umso mehr hoffen Barbara und Thomas,
dass er ihnen tatsächlich
eine Offerte schicken wird.
40 °C und Sonnenschein. Selbst
für den Strand ist es zu heiss.
Hier unten ist der Fleischwolf.
Er ist schwer wie die Hölle.
Dort ist das Dach des Zelts.
Schon seit Stunden
sind Anita und Alain am Einräumen.
Wir standen früh auf.
Wir gingen um 3 Uhr zu Bett
und standen um 6 Uhr auf.
Wir wollten draussen die ersten
Sonnenstrahlen geniessen ...
... und sehen, wie das Wetter wird.
Es war bedeckt, neblig und dunstig.
Einfach herrlich.
Die Stimmung ist gut, trotz der
vielen Arbeit, die auf sie wartet.
Die beiden müssen das Chaos
rund um das Haus beseitigen.
Bereits vor sechs Wochen brachte ein
Zügelunternehmen ihre Möbel hierher.
Seitdem war ihr Hausrat
ungeschützt der Witterung ausgesetzt.
Das nervt noch ein bisschen.
Das hier sind meine Boxen.
Aber sie sehen noch gut aus.
Etwas schade ist, dass ein altes
Möbelstück meiner Grossmutter
im Regen stand.
Aber da es Massivholz ist, kann man
es anschleifen und dann ist es gut.
Ansonsten ist es nicht so schlimm.
Fast alles, was sie besassen, haben
sie ins neue Zuhause mitgenommen.
In der Schweiz findet man
auf ricardo.ch 100 Betten.
Die will niemand.
Hier gibt es keinen Occasionsmarkt.
Es ist alles relativ teuer.
Daher ergab es für uns
wenig Sinn ...
... das Zeug wegzuschmeissen,
wenn wir es später wieder brauchen.
Daher nahmen wir alles mit.
Nur: Wohin mit all den Sachen?
So.
Jetzt heben wir es so hoch.
- Genau.
Soll ich es an den Beinen halten?
- Genau.- Gut.
In Biglen im Emmental bewohnten
die beiden ein grosses Bauernhaus.
Hier müssen sich Alain und Anita
auf drei Zimmer beschränken.
Diese Nacht wird im Bett
nicht herumgezappelt.
Ich werde versuchen,
mich wenig zu bewegen.
Juhu.
Das Bett aufzustellen,
ist das Zeichen,
dass wir wirklich hierbleiben.
Genau.
- Nicht wahr?
Nun sind wir wirklich hier.
Auch ihre Schildkröten und Schlangen
sollen hier so schnell wie möglich
ein Zuhause finden.
Gehen wir rüber?
Vor dem Umzug
haben sie für die Landschildkröten
bereits
ein erstes Gehege bauen lassen.
Es sieht gut aus, nicht wahr?
Er ist gut gespannt
und reicht bis nach unten.
Es ist ganz unten befestigt.
Dann passen sie nicht unten durch.
Das ist nicht mehr viel Arbeit.
- Nein.
Es fehlt nur noch der Sichtschutz,
damit sie nicht immer
am Zaun entlanggehen.
Das ist ja tipptopp.
Das Schildkrötengehege
ist aber erst der Anfang.
Als Nächstes wollen sie auf ihrem
Grundstück drei Teiche anlegen
und fünf Bungalows bauen.
Ihre Idee: Ferien und Ausflüge
für Reptilienfreunde anbieten.
* Ruhige Musik *
Als frisch Zugezogene sind sie
aber auf Unterstützung angewiesen.
So wie die von Nachbar Hans
oder Makler Georgios.
Georgios, kalimera.
- Kalimera, Georgios.
* Er spricht griechisch. *
Herzlich willkommen und viel Spass.
Vielen Dank für die Eier im
Kühlschrank. Auch Öl ist schon da.
Egal, egal. Das ist normal.
Hallo, Georgios.
- Alles gut?
Alles tipptopp.
- Schön.
Super.
- Wir sind auch froh, hier zu sein.
* Sie sagen etwas auf Griechisch
und Barbara wiederholt es. *
Das heisst viel Glück.
Ihr könnt mir ja erzählen,
was ihr wollt.
Stimmt's?
* Alle lachen. *
Seen und Wald -
so weit das Auge reicht -
und mittendrin eine Ferienanlage:
das neue Zuhause von Familie Rotzler.
Zwei Tage lang
waren sie mit ihren Kindern
von der Schweiz aus unterwegs.
(Mann) Schau, jetzt kommen sie.
Sabrinas Eltern haben den Transporter
mit den Umzugskisten gefahren.
Kennst du uns noch?
Hallo.
- Hallo. Wo ist Sam?
* Pfiff *
Geschafft.
Wir haben ihn müde gemacht.
Hallo, hallo.- Hallo.
Riecht ihr das?
- Die Mücken spüren wir.
Nein, die Freiheit.
- Aha.
Ich finde die Mücken lästig.
- Ja, die gibt es.
Wusstet ihr das?
- Ja, ja.- So viele Mücken?
(Mann) Hallo.
- (Jonas) Hej.
Welcome to Sweden.
* Jonas lacht. *
Hej.
- Hej.
Kaum da, schaut Nachbar Ulf
mit seiner Frau Eva vorbei.
(Schwedisch)
Ulf und Eva wohnen
ein paar Hundert Meter entfernt.
Die Schweizer haben sie bei
ihrem letzten Besuch kennengelernt.
Vor zwei Monaten waren sie hier
zur Vertragsunterzeichnung.
Hej.
Oh!
- Ui!
* Lachen *
(Schwedisch)
Alles Gute.
* Sanfte Musik *
Hier durchzugehen ist besser,
als oben durchzugehen, was?
Hier.
- Ich schaue zu.
Es war total seltsam, als ich
im Auto zu den Kindern sagte:
"Wir sind gleich zu Hause."
Bis vor ein paar Tagen
hatten wir ein anderes Zuhause.
Nun sagen wir:
"Wir sind gleich zu Hause."
Aber es ist total schön.
* Sanfte Musik *
6,5 ha Land -
so viel wie neun Fussballfelder -,
mehrere Gästehäuser, ein Restaurant,
diverse Geräteschuppen
und Werkstätten
kann Familie Rotzler
nun ihr Eigen nennen.
Ein Anwesen mit gut 20 Holzhäusern.
V.a. Outdoor-Fans
sowie Lang- und Orientierungsläufer
waren bei den Vorbesitzern zu Gast.
(Englisch)
Unter dem Schnee
erwarteten uns keine Überraschungen.
Es hätte ja sein können,
dass Müllberge rumliegen,
aber das ist nicht so.
Nun haben wir drei Wochen Zeit. Es
gibt natürlich sehr viel zu tun.
Dann eröffnen wir die Anlage.
Bis Ende Jahr
werden wir viel arbeiten müssen,
aber das wussten wir von Anfang.
Es ist wunderschön.
Mir gefällt es total,
noch besser als mit Schnee.
Es ist der Hammer.
Fiona, das ist dein Wald.
Meiner?
- Der Wald von uns allen.
Das ist unser Wald.
Daher ist es auch dein Wald.
Schau, da sind nochmals Blumen.
Die erste Nacht verbringen sie
in einem der Ferienhäuser.
Fiona, weisst du noch?
Das Bett ist bereit.
Nach der Vertragsunterzeichnung
im Winter
hatten sie sich hier
bereits eingerichtet.
Kannst du übernehmen?
Das ist gewürzt,
das gesalzen und das ungewürzt.
Kommst du nachher und würzt es?
- Das darfst du machen.
Weisst du was, Fiona? Das ist
schon fast ein Mitternachtssnack.
Es ist schon 23 Uhr.
- Mama, Mama!
Die erste Etappe
ins neue Leben ist geschafft.
8 Uhr in der Früh in Kanada.
Thomas muss zur Arbeit.
- Tschüss, Hasi.
Fahr vorsichtig.
- Mach ich.
Bis später.
Bis ihr Projekt mit dem Gästehaus
beginnt, jobbt Thomas in einem Café.
Ich bin dort - salopp formuliert -
Mädchen für alles.
Das Café wird von guten Freunden
von uns betrieben.
Dass ich dort nebenbei
auf Stundenbasis
noch ein paar Dollar verdienen kann,
ist eine gute Sache und hilft uns.
Eine knappe Stunde Fahrt ist es
bis ins Zentrum von Charlottetown,
der Provinzhauptstadt
von Prince Edward Island.
Dort liegt das Café.
Good morning, hello.
Thomas ist in der Gastronomie
und Hotellerie zu Hause.
Rund 25 Jahre arbeitet er
schon in diesem Metier.
Durch den Job will der 48-Jährige
auch sein Englisch verbessern
und das kanadische Arbeitsleben
kennenlernen.
Zu Hause
versucht Ehefrau Barbara derweil,
bei den Behörden Druck zu machen.
Die Baubewilligung muss jetzt
so schnell wie möglich kommen.
* Freizeichen *
Das ist jetzt ein Klassiker:
Es ist Donnerstag um 9.45 Uhr.
In der Schweiz
wären das normale Geschäftszeiten,
aber hier geschieht es sehr häufig,
dass man die Leute
einfach nicht erreichen kann.
Was steht da?
"Mount service ..."
Wer ist das? Keine Ahnung.
Hi there.
- Morning.- Hi, hi.
Thank you.
* Sie lacht. *
Der unerwartete Besucher
will das Grundstück vermessen.
Die alten Pläne des Hauses
werden für die Baugenehmigung
nicht mehr akzeptiert.
Vielleicht auch ein Grund
für die Verzögerung.
Wir müssen etwas vermessen lassen,
was wir vor 1 1/2 Jahren kauften
und damals schon vermessen wurde.
Beim Bau vor zwölf Jahren wurde
das Haus auch schon mal vermessen.
Well, you have to play by the rules.
Das ist einfach so.
Wir sind am kürzeren Hebel.
Genau.
So manches läuft anders in Kanada.
Das wird Barbara
von Tag zu Tag mehr bewusst.
In Griechenland muss als Nächstes
der Wohnwagen rauf auf den Berg.
(Mann auf Englisch)
(Anita)
Er könnte ihn sicher hochziehen.
Mhm.
Das ist ein Unimog.
Alain und Anita
haben sich für den Transport
extra einen Geländewagen geliehen -
bei ihren neuen Nachbarn.
2 km Schotterpiste
müssen sie bewältigen.
Immer wieder geht es steil bergauf.
Nein, nein, nein.
Er schafft es nicht.
Er hat zu wenig Power.
Der Geländewagen hat zu wenig Kraft,
um den schweren Wohnwagen
über das steilste Stück zu ziehen.
Aber so schnell
will Alain nicht aufgeben.
Okay?
- Ja.
Darf ich etwas sagen?
Wir ziehen hinten und vorn
die Bremse an
und lassen ihn stehen,
damit er nicht überhitzt.
Ja.
Dann rufst du Georgios an
und fragst nach einem Traktor.- Ja.
Hallo, Georgios,
wir haben ein riesiges Problem.
Wir stehen mit dem Wohnwagen
und Johns Auto
mitten auf dem Kiesweg und kommen
weder vorwärts noch rückwärts.
Wir sind wirklich Helden.
Nicht wahr?
- Mhm.
Regst du dich auf?
- Ja, etwas.
Nagt es an deinem Stolz?
Ja, und wenn der keine Zeit hat?
Wer als Erster kommt,
muss uns helfen.- Ja.
Es wird eine Lösung geben.
Wir sind in Griechenland.
Mhm.
- Du wirst schon sehen.
* Grillenzirpen *
Sie ist die Vernunft von uns beiden.
Sie ist die Vernunft
und ich bin eher derjenige,
der es einfach mal versucht
und etwas durchstieren will.
In fünf Fällen klappt das
und man schafft es in kürzerer Zeit,
und in den anderen fünf Fällen
klappt es nicht.
Dann wäre ihre Vorgehensweise
einfacher gewesen.
Dann wollen wir mal hoffen ...
... dass die Verständigung
funktioniert.
* Ruhige Musik *
Dann endlich,
nach 1 Std. warten in der Hitze.
Willst du mit ihm runterfahren?
Der Olivenbauer ist ein Bekannter
von Makler Georgios.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Mit dem Traktor
ist alles kein Problem.
Auf die richtigen Kontakte kommt es
an - offenbar auch in Griechenland.
Tag 1 im neuen Leben
von Familie Rotzler in Schweden.
Boah, ich muss
wirklich Wäsche waschen.
Zeit für den Haushalt aber
hat Familie Rotzler noch keine.
Sie ist mit den Vorbesitzern
zur Schlüsselübergabe verabredet.
Wollen wir los?
- Ja.
Sie sind immer zu früh dran.
Ich lege die Tasche ins Auto.
Ich gehe mit Kian zu Fuss.
Wenn er mitwill, muss er gehen.
Komm, Kian.
Komm, Kian. Wir gehen durch den
Wald, beim Bach über die Brücke.
Rennen!
* Sie macht ermunternde Geräusche. *
Schau, dort ist Ake. Hej.
Hej, Ake. Hej, tack.
Vorbesitzer Ake
und seine Frau Elisabeth
führten den Betrieb 17 Jahre lang.
Altershalber
wollen sie die Anlage abgeben.
(Englisch)
Wow!
Auch Makler Björn ist da.
Er wickelt den Verkauf ab.
(Kian) Heiss.
- Dir ist heiss?
Warm? Nun musst du halt mitkommen.
Du wolltest mit.
Nun kommst du halt mit rein.
He likes chocolate, candies.
Jonas und Sabrina
übernehmen nicht nur die Immobilie,
sondern auch
die Firma der Vorbesitzer.
Von nun an sind sie Unternehmer -
und selbstständig.
Bist du heute der Chef?
- Nein.
Nun kann nichts mehr schiefgehen.
Wir haben bezahlt und
die Verträge sind unterschrieben.
Dies ist nur noch
die offizielle Übergabe.
Tack.
Yes, welcome to Sweden.
(Heidi) Oh, ja, schaut, das
könnt ihr aufteilen und reintragen.
(Sabrinas Vater) Einen für Kian.
- (Heidi) Einen?
(Heidi) Das schaffst du.
Du kannst alle tragen.
Hier rein, auf einen der Stapel.
In den Vorraum.
(Sabrinas Vater)
Das braucht sie wohl.
Eine Woche haben sich
Heidi und Thomas freigeschaufelt,
um Tochter und Schwiegersohn
beim Umzug zu unterstützen.
Schon bald müssen Jonas und Sabrina
Kinder und Geschäft allein managen.
(Heidi) Schau,
da ist noch ganz viel Zeug.
Sie werden das schon hinkriegen.
Da bin ich optimistisch.
Sie müssen es hinkriegen.
Denn wir gehen
in ein paar Tagen nach Hause.
Aber ich denke,
sie haben hier auch Unterstützung.
Eva und Ulf haben bereits angeboten,
die Kinder mal zu hüten,
wenn es nötig ist.
Daher bin ich optimistisch.
Very nice.
- Tack, Björn, tack sa mycket.
Alles erledigt.
- Thank you.
* Er spricht schwedisch. *
(Englisch)
Die Erleichterung bei Vorbesitzer Ake
und seiner Frau Elisabeth ist gross.
Viel zu lange suchten sie
nach einem passenden Käufer.
Elisabeth.
(Englisch)
Oh!
Verkauft heisst für Ake
aber nicht vergessen.
Bei Fragen darf sich Jonas
auch in Zukunft an ihn wenden.
(Englisch)
Jetzt kriegen wir
noch ein paar Schlüssel.
Was heisst Schlüssel auf Schwedisch?
Nyckel.
- Nyckel.
Smile.
Umdrehen.
Nimmst du ihn?
- Dreh dich um.
Ab jetzt beginnt
für Jonas und Sabrina die Arbeit.
Wird es den beiden gelingen,
die in die Jahre gekommene Anlage
wieder zum Laufen zu bringen?
Die Offerte fürs Sandstrahlen
haben Barbara und Thomas
tatsächlich bekommen.
Aber kaum ist ein Problem gelöst,
tauchen in Kanada zwei neue auf.
Noch immer warten sie
auf die Baubewilligung.
Ausserdem müssen sie
neue Öltanks einbauen lassen.
Und auch die Gas-Cheminées
brauchen neue Sensoren.
Es tauchten viele Kosten auf, mit
denen wir nicht gerechnet hatten.
Wir hoffen nun einfach,
dass die Leute willig sind,
vielleicht 20 Dollar mehr pro Nacht
zu bezahlen.
Dann würde es
unter dem Strich wieder aufgehen,
aber das wissen wir nicht.
Für die Realisierung ihres Traums
riskieren sie viel.
In das Mansion am Meer stecken sie
fast ihr gesamtes Vermögen,
einen Erbvorbezug
und die Pensionskassen.
Zusätzlich
mussten sie sich verschulden.
Umgerechnet 1,4 Mio. Fr.
haben sie budgetiert.
Trotzdem wird das Geld langsam knapp.
Da heisst es gut rechnen und sparen,
wo immer es geht.
Die sind zu klein
für die Kartoffelmaschine.
Die Kartoffelmaschine
erntet die kleinen Kartoffeln nicht.
Aber ich ...
... finde kleine Kartoffeln
viel cooler als grosse.
Es sind unzählige.
Es ist alles voll davon.
Das Feld wurde bereits abgeerntet.
Was liegen blieb,
darf Barbara mitnehmen.
Ich finde es total cool,
dass ich vor meiner Haustür
Kartoffeln sammeln kann.
Ich finde das irgendwie erfüllend.
Auf ungemütliche Zeiten haben sich
Barbara und Thomas eingestellt.
Sie haben kühl gerechnet
und sind nicht blauäugig
nach Kanada aufgebrochen.
Aber dass sie so viel Ausdauer
brauchen, hätten sie nicht gedacht.
* Ruhige Musik *
In der Schweiz sassen wir
natürlich im gemachten Nest.
Diese Sicherheit gaben wir auf.
Aber wenn wir
an einem sonnigen Tag zurückblicken,
sagen wir uns:
"Doch, das war es wert."
(Navigationsgerät)
Das Ziel befindet sich rechts.
112 Longworth Avenue.
Ziel erreicht.
Ihre optimistische Art hilft Barbara.
Sie will sich
nicht entmutigen lassen.
Obwohl der Umbau
noch nicht einmal begonnen hat,
liess die 45-Jährige bereits
Flyer für das Gästehaus drucken.
Okay, thank you very much.
"45 Steps -
The Culinary Beachside Inn".
"45 Steps",
weil es genau 45 Treppenstufen
von unserem Haus bis zum Meer sind.
Genau.
So.
Ihr Inn am Strand wäre längst offen,
ginge es nach den ursprünglichen
Plänen von Barbara und Thomas.
Durch die Pandemie aber
verloren sie schon mehr als ein Jahr.
Und die fehlende Baubewilligung
behindert die Schweizer
nun aufs Neue.
Auf Prince Edward Island
herrscht eine extreme Saisonalität.
Juli und August sind die Monate,
in denen man Umsatz macht.
Wenn wir im Juli und im August
nicht geöffnet haben,
haben wir ganz klar
ein finanzielles Problem.
Wenn die Baubewilligung
nicht bald kommt,
verpassen sie die nächste Saison.
Und dann wäre ihr Projekt mit
dem Gästehaus ernsthaft gefährdet.
* Sanfte Musik *
Auf dem griechischen Peloponnes
haben Anita und Alain zum ersten Mal
einen freien Nachmittag.
Alains erstes Schwimmerlebnis -
nach fünf Tagen Stress,
Einräumen und Dinge rumschleppen.
Heute ist das
noch etwas aussergewöhnlich,
aber später wird es wohl
ein tägliches Bild sein.
In der Schweiz wäre Alain
um diese Zeit noch bei einem Kunden
und würde
elektrische Anlagen überprüfen.
Anita sässe im Büro, um Personal
bei der Spitex zu disponieren.
Für ihr Hobby mit den Reptilien
blieben den beiden
nur die Abende und das Wochenende.
An diesem Strandabschnitt
legen die Meeresschildkröten
im Juni jeweils ihre Eier.
Für mich geht schon
ein Traum in Erfüllung.
Das Schlüpfen von Meeresschildkröten
erlebte ich noch nie live.
Nächstes Jahr habe ich
vielleicht sogar die Chance,
sie beim Eierlegen
beobachten zu können.
Darauf freue ich mich wahnsinnig.
War es schön?
- Ja.- Hast du es genossen?
Ich umarme dich nicht,
sonst bist du nass.
Fast schon perfektes Glück.
Es fehlen nur noch die Reptilien.
* Ruhige Musik *
Alain will das Becken
für die Wasserschildkröten reinigen,
damit bei der Ankunft der Tiere
alles bereit ist.
Dann werde ich sehen,
ob es dicht ist.
Die 41 Schildkröten und 24 Gift-
schlangen sind noch im Emmental.
Sie werden dort
von Freunden versorgt.
Nächste Woche muss ich
wieder in die Schweiz.
Die Gehege von gewissen Tieren
müssen gereinigt werden.
Ich habe noch eine Mäusezucht.
Ich kann den netten Leuten,
die sich um unsere Tiere kümmern,
ja nicht zumuten,
den Mäusekäfig auszumisten.
Das Problem:
Die griechischen Behörden
stellen die Einfuhrbewilligung
für die Tiere einfach nicht aus.
Die Anwältin, die Alain und Anita
mit der Beschaffung der Papiere
beauftragten,
kommt auch nicht weiter -
seit Wochen schon.
Wir haben eine Bewilligung,
um die Tiere zu halten.
Diese ist länderspezifisch.
Nun geht es
um internationales Recht,
um Handelsrecht -
wie bei Kaffee, Zucker usw.
Diese Handelspapiere
müssen sie unterschreiben.
Für mich ist es unverständlich,
dass sich das so in die Länge zieht.
Nun lasse ich es
mal etwas einweichen.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Auf und davon":
Ein lustiger Sessel.
Jonas und Sabrina bereiten alles
für die ersten Gäste vor.
Das sind zwei schöne Zimmer.
Dabei machen sie
einen unangenehmen Fund.
Oh, jetzt weiss ich,
weshalb es so stank.
Das ist ein lustiges Tier,
das ich noch nicht kenne.
Winter in Kanada.
Endlich
kann der Umbau der Villa beginnen.
Cool, was?
Barbara und Thomas müssen in
ihrem riesigen Haus zusammenrücken.
Das ist unser Schlaf-Wohnzimmer,
etwa 3 mal 4 m2 gross -
wenn überhaupt.
Und: Drama in Griechenland.
Dort hinten
sahen wir zuerst nur Rauch.
Plötzlich kam das Feuer über den
Berg und man sah oben alles brennen.
Das Haus von Anita und Alain
brennt bis auf die Grundmauern ab.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt sprachlos.
* Düstere Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023